- [Instructor] What I want
to do in this video is
to talk a little bit
about spectrophotometry.
Spectrophotometry, photometry,
which sounds fairly sophisticated,
but it's really based on
a fairly simple principle.
So if I have, let's say
we have two solutions
that contain some type of solute.
So that is solution one, and
then this is solution two.
And let's just assume that our
beakers have the same width.
Now let's say solution,
let me put it right here.
Number one, and number two.
Now let's say that solution one
has less of the solute in it.
So let me, let me make...
So that's the water line right there.
So this guy has less of it,
and let's say it's yellow,
or to our eyes, it looks yellow.
So this has less of it.
So this hasm actuallym
let me do it this way.
Let me shade it in like this.
So it has less of it.
And let's say solution number
two has more of the solute,
so it's more.
So I'll just kind of represent that
as more closely packed lines.
So the concentration of
the solute is higher here.
So let me write higher concentration.
Higher concentration.
Concentration, and let's say,
and this is a lower, lower concentration.
Now let's think about what will happen
if we shine some light
through each of these beakers,
and let's just assume that we
are shining at a wavelength
of light that is specific to the...
That that is specifically
sensitive to the solute
that we have dissolved in here.
But I'll just leave that
pretty general right now.
So let's say I have some
light here of some intensity.
So let's just call that...
Let's call that the incident intensity.
I'll just say that it's
I0, so it's some intensity.
What's going to happen as the light exits
the other side of this beaker right here?
Well, some of it is going to be absorbed
by our little molecules inside the beaker,
so you're going to have less light
come out to the other side.
I'll call this I1.
Now, in this situation, if
we shined the same amount
of light into this beaker, so
it's the same number that is,
that is the same, the
same intensity of light,
what's going to happen?
Well, more is going to
be absorbed as the light
travels through this beaker.
It's just going to bump
into more molecules,
'cause it's a higher concentration here.
So the light that comes out when you have
a higher concentration, I'll
call that the intensity,
I'll call that I2, this is going to have
a lower intensity of light
that's being transmitted
than this one over here.
In this case, I2 is going
to have a lower intensity,
is going to be less than I1.
If you have another beaker
that is maybe twice as wide,
it's twice as wide, and
let's say it has the same
concentration as number
two, we'll call this one
number three, it has the same
concentration as number two.
So I'll try to make it
look fairly similar,
and you were to shine some light in here.
Let's say you shine
the same light in here,
and you have some light that
makes it through, that exits,
and then this is actually
what your eyes would see.
So this is I3 right there.
What do you think's going to happen?
Well, it's the same
concentration, but this light
has to travel a further
distance of that concentration.
So once again, it's going
to bump into more molecules
and more of it will be absorbed,
and so less light will be transmitted.
So I2 is less than I1, and I3,
I3 is actually going to be the least.
And if you were looking at
these, this has the least light,
this has a little bit more
light being transmitted,
this has the most light being transmitted.
So if you were to look at this,
if you placed your eyeball right here,
this one right here would
have the lightest color.
You're getting the most
light into your eye.
This would be a slightly darker color,
and this would be the darkest color.
That makes complete sense.
If you dissolve something,
if you dissolve a little bit
of something in water, it will
still be pretty transparent.
If you dissolve a lot
of something in water,
it'll be more opaque.
And if the cup that you're dissolving in,
or the beaker that you're
in, gets even longer,
it'll get even more opaque.
So hopefully, that gives you the intuition
behind spectrophotometry.
And so the next question is, well,
what is it even good for?
Why would I even care?
Well, you could actually
use this information.
You could see how much
light is transmitted
versus how much you put
in to actually figure out
the concentration of a solution.
That's why we're even talking about it
in a chemistry context.
So before we do that,
and I'll show you an example
of that in the next video,
let me just define some,
really, some terms of ways
of measuring how concentrated this is,
or ways of measuring how
much light is transmitted
versus how much was put in.
So the first thing I will
define is transmittance.
And so when the people
who defined it said, well,
you know, what we care about
is how much is transmitted
versus how much went in, so
let's just define transmittance
as that ratio.
So in this example, the
transmittance of number one
would be the amount that got through
over the amount that you put in.
Over here, the transmittance
would be the amount
that you got out over the
amount that you put in.
And as we see, this one right
here will be a lower number.
I2 is lower than I1,
so this will have a lower
transmittance then number one.
So let's call this transmittance two.
This is transmittance one.
And transmittance three is
the light that comes out,
that gets through, over
the light that goes in,
and this is the smallest
number, followed by that,
followed by that.
So this will have the least transmittance,
it's the most opaque, followed
by that, followed by that.
Now another definition,
which is really kind of
a derivative of the transmittance,
and not in the calculus sense,
it's just derived from
transmittance, and we'll see,
it has pretty neat properties,
is the notion of absorbance.
And so here, we're trying to measure,
how good is it at absorbing?
This is measuring, how good
are you at transmitting?
A higher number says
you're transmitting a lot,
but absorbance is how
good you're absorbing,
so it's kind of the opposite.
If you're good at transmitting,
that means you're bad at absorbing,
You don't have a lot to absorb.
If you're good at absorbing,
that means you're not transmitting much.
So absorbance.
Absorbance, right here,
and absorbance is defined
as the negative log of transmittance.
And this logarithm is base 10,
or you could view that if the
transmittance, we've already
defined as the negative, the
negative log of the light
that is transmitted over
the light that is input,
but the easiest way is the negative log
of the transmittance.
And so, if transmittance
is a large number,
absorbance is a small
number, which makes sense.
Now, what's also cool about this.
is there something called
the Beer-Lambert law,
which you could verify, and this is...
We'll actually use this in the next video,
Beer-Lambert law.
I actually don't know the
history of where it came from,
and I'm sure it's based
on somebody named Beer,
but I always imagined it's
based on someone transmitting
light through beer, the Beer-Lambert law.
And this tells us, this
tells us that the absorbance
is proportional to the path length.
So this would be, how far
does the light have to go
through the solution?
So it's proportional to the path length
times the concentration,
times the concentration.
Usually we use molarity
for the concentration.
Or another way to say it
is that the absorbance
is equal to some constant.
It's usually a lowercase
Epsilon like that.
Some constant, and this is
dependent on the solution,
or the solute in question,
what we actually have in here
and the temperature and the
pressure and all of that.
It's equal to constant times
the length it has to travel,
times the concentration.
Let me make it clear right here.
This thing right here,
this thing right here is concentration.
Concentration.
The reason why this is super
useful, as you can imagine,
so let's say we have an axis right here.
That's axis, and over here,
I'm measuring concentration.
This is our concentration axis,
and we're measuring it as molarity.
And let's say the molarity starts at zero.
It goes, you know, I
don't know, .1, .2, .3,
so on and so forth.
And over here, you are
measuring absorbance.
In the vertical axis
you measure absorbance.
Now, let's say you have some solution,
and you know the concentration,
you know it is a .1 molar concentration.
So let me write down M for molar.
And you measure its absorbance
and you just get some number here.
So you measure its absorbance
and you get its absorbance,
so this is a low concentration,
didn't absorb that much.
You get, I don't know some number here,
so let's say it's .25.
And then let's say that
you then take another known
concentration, let's say .2 molar,
and you say that, oh
look, it has an absorbance
right here at .5, and I should
put a zero in front of these.
0.5 and 0.25.
What this tells you, this
is a linear relationship.
For any concentration,
the absorbance is going to be on a line.
And if you want a little
review of algebra,
Epsilon times the length
will be the slope.
But the important thing to realize
is that you have a line here.
You have a line here, and why?
And the reason that's useful
is you could use a little bit
of algebra, figure out
the equation of a line,
or you could just look at it
graphically and say, okay,
I had two known concentrations,
and I was able to figure
out the absorbance.
You can then go the other way around.
You could then measure for
some unknown concentration.
You could figure out its absorbance.
So let's say there's some
unknown concentration,
and you figure out its
absorbance is right over here.
Let's say it's .4.
Then you can just go on this
line right here, and you say,
okay, well then that must be,
that must be a
concentration of this, well,
whatever number this is.
And you could measure it,
or you could actually
figure it out algebraically.
And so this will be
pretty close to .2 molar,
a little bit less than 0.2 molar.
And we're gonna actually
do an example of that
in the next video.